[Music]
you mentioned age your birthday you had
a birthday recently how did you
celebrate your birthday
well I'm 51 years old right the days of
strippers and booze are over it's over
so you're gonna go for the ones at all
where have you been
revue bit no that stuff is over so you
know what I did I went to the Central
Park Zoo in New York City in fact I have
a picture can you guys put it up sure
look at that yeah I'm the one on the
left yeah right two old goats that's
what I thought you have a good time at
the zoo did you enjoy yourself well
actually now that I'm looking at that I
think that was a tinder date I apologize
I enjoy the zoo I love animals then do
you I do
yeah yeah why not there's some animals
that I think we can you know I don't
know like a lizard like that's a big pet
now lizards you know but for those of
you think you might want a lizard as a
pet here's what you should do
go home draw eyes on a shoe and talk to
it alright not a dynamic pair and you
know New York City dogs and cats rule
yeah and where the cat people because
we'll talk about you guys cat people are
great I know cats are the gateway pet to
hoarding but I'll tell ya no dogs you
know like they're very very
sophisticated now the in fact like you
know my roommates dog is on ambien cuz
he has nightmares believe that yeah the
dog has nightmares
dog nightmares on ambien yeah the
nightmares yeah now I cannot believe
like a dog would have a nightmare cuz I
think they have a great life I mean they
don't work you know I mean they just
play and eat I mean I'm like looking at
the dog he's just yelping and barking
and its paws are moving I'm like what is
it boy is there a ball under a couch in
your mind somewhere
was there someone at the door but they
weren't there and then you thought they
were there you had a run back daddy
I never know what to do when you see a
dog having a nightmare no no no just not
much I just pulled my pants and leave
the room all right listen hook it into
the gutter really you had to do it you
did what you had to do
did you know you mentioned that you're
51 and I'm just curious so you are you
experiencing any of the changes you know
people experience as they get a little
older do you feel like pretty much the
same well that's a very polite way to
get into what I want to talk about which
is my nutsack
it is just Wow and it's not what I was
getting into
doesn't say nutsack anywhere here well
let me just say one thing when you get
older that keeps growing all right and
to begin with I don't think that whoever
made the nut sack was really thinking
because it doesn't look good to me
I mean someone was like oh let's take
something very prescient and put and put
it in a sack with seven hairs on it and
let it be vulnerable to everything I
don't like that so I'm sorry if I got
all emotional about to start crying I'll
let you cheered up a little bit so
you're saying and let me get this judge
let's do it you're not happy about that
area of your body because it's changing
its changing its changing getting bigger
it's getting bigger actually my nutsack
looks like a tent no one knows how to
fold up it's everywhere
[Applause]
yeah really I think it's gonna get
continue to get larger over time I don't
know why I'm continuing this we've
learned a scientific discovery now and I
should find out more I'm gonna say this
all I'm gonna say okay like when I died
don't waste money on a coffin all right
don't just pull my nut sack over my head
and throw me in the ocean let me in
there okay all right well I'll be sure
I'm at that service
you